you’ve been subjected to watching The Notebook
with your spouse, you might have experienced
an uncomfortable lump in your throat.
As you attempt to breath heavy and avoid crying
like a little kid who has just skinned her
knee, you might wonder, what causes the feeling
of a lump in your throat?
For that matter, why do we cry when we’re
sad?
The lump in your throat has a rather easy
explanation compared to crying when emotionally
upset.
Known as the globus sensation, the feeling
is the result of a battle between the opposing
forces of muscles attached to your glottis
(the opening between your vocal cords).
It tends to present itself when sad, or when
you swallow or hold your breath to avoid crying.
There are only two autonomic nervous systems
in the body, sympathetic and parasympathetic-
sympathetic being your fight or flight nervous
system, and the opposing parasympathetic being
stimulated by resting and relaxing (your feed
or breed nervous system).
When you begin feeling upset, or have any
stressful experience, your body stimulates
its sympathetic nervous system via the HPA
axis.
This axis involves a connection between your
hypothalamus, pituitary gland and your adrenal
glands.
It will release hormones in to your blood
stream causing things like increased heart
rate, blood pressure, and metabolism.
It will then sense it needs more oxygen to
maintain that experience.
It’s your sympathetic nervous system at
work when you try to avoid breaking down and
it feels like you’ve swallowed a golf ball.
Your body responds to this sympathetic drive
by opening your glottis via the posterior
crioaryteniod and thyroarytenoid muscles.
The result gives a larger opening for oxygen
to enter your lungs.
When you attempt to swallow, or hold your
breath to avoid sobbing, your lateral cricoarytenoid,
aryepiglottic, and thyroepiglottic muscles
constrict, struggling to close off your glottis.
These opposing forces cause the sensation
of a giant lump in your throat.
lacrimal-glandCrying, or more specifically
shedding tears, in response to an emotional
stimulus is a much more complex issue.
To begin with, tears are produced by the almond
shaped lacrimal glands situated on the outside
portion of your orbit.
Depending on the type of stimulus, the glands
will produce three different tears.
The first kind are basal tears.
They get released every time you blink, serving
to lubricate the eye and keep it free from
dust or drying out.
The second type are reflex tears.
They get released in response to an irritant,
such as can be introduced when cutting onions.
(see:Why Does Cutting Onions Make Your Eyes
Water?)
These two types of tears are composed of pretty
much the same stuff- things like water, salt,
potassium, lipids, and the antibacterial lysozyme.
Emotional tears are another thing altogether.
There doesn’t seem to be a consensus among
researchers as to exactly why they spring
up.
Their make-up does, however, provide some
clues to their origin.
For instance, they contain hormones like ACTH
(adrenocorticotropin hormone) and prolactin,
20-25% more protein groups, and 30 times more
manganese than normal tears.
ACTH is the hormone released by your HPA axis
when your sympathetic nervous system is in
charge.
Prolactin is also elevated in response to
stress.
Manganese has long been known to help regulate
your mood, and those who are constantly depressed
will usually have higher levels in their blood
stream.
Emotional tears also contain leucine enkephalin.
This is an opioid peptide giving you the same
pain-killing effects morphine does.
On that note, some posit that crying in response
to having your sympathetic nervous system
stimulated by an emotional event has evolutionary
benefits in that it’s a way humans can signal
the need for help during those trying times.
(Or signal empathy for someone like in the
case of sympathizing with James Garners’
character, Noah, when his children ask him
to come home as his wife, and their mother,
doesn’t recognize him or know he’s there
anyway.
In response, he says, “Look, guys, that’s
my sweetheart in there.
I’m not leaving her.
This is my home now.
Your mother is my home…” *sniffle*)
If this is true, then the presence of ACTH
and prolactin could account for that.
Women generally have higher levels of prolactin
in their bodies, so this could also be the
reason why women cry on average five times
more than men.
Chronically depressed people seem to cry more
often, and they also tend to have higher levels
of manganese in their system.
Others point out the healing benefits of the
act as the main reason why we cry.
First off, there is the aforementioned presence
of leucine enkephalin, giving you the mood-lifting
feelings any opiate would.
Secondly, there are plenty of studies showing
the calming effects of crying, leading many
to argue it’s an involuntary way our bodies
can calm down from a stressful event.
This theory is furthered by other studies
showing that if you disable nerves that stimulate
the sympathetic nervous system, you will cry
more.
Should you damage the important nerves involved
with the parasympathetic nervous system, you
will cry less.
This would lead one to conclude that it’s
not the stressful event that triggers the
crying, but the need for our ancestors to
calm down after a stressful event, helping
to make sure they don’t die of a heart attack
from the continual fight or flight response.